hello in this short video we'll talk
about spirochaetes
spirochaetes are
long helically coiled corkscrew-shaped
cells
they are bacteria and they are generally
gram negative in nature
they contain distinctive diderm or a
double membrane organization
their length is about three to five
hundred microns whereas their diameter
varies from point zero nine to three
micron
spirochaetes are distinguished from
other bacteria
by their location of flagella and this
kind of flagella is known as
endoflagellar which runs inside the
bacterial
membrane so
this particular flagella runs through
the periplasmic space
and this particular endoflagellar has a
important function
it allows this particular bacteria
to undergo a twisting motion
and this twisting motion is really
important while this particular bacteria
is wading its way through a thick mucus
let's say
and thereby it can attach to host cells
and this kind of motion gives the
spirochetes a nice pathogenicity
then spirochetes from a nutritional
point of view are chemoheterotrophic in
nature that means they use organic
carbon
as a carbon source and they use
energy which comes from oxidation of
organic or inorganic substances
many spirochetes are pathogenic to human
such as
leptospira which cause
leptospirosis which is characterized by
high fever headache chills abdominal
pain vomiting etc
syphilis which is a sexually transmitted
disease is caused by the spirochete
triponima palladium
generally
this triponima pallidum is acquired
while having a core intercourse or close
sexual contact these pathogens can bore
through the squamous and columnar
epithelia and can reach the host's body
triponima pallidium can be
detected with the help of silver
staining in otherwise yellowish
background in silver staining they would
appear
black
now borelia
bergdorferi is another
spyro kit who is responsible for lime
fever
which is characterized by high fever
headache fatigue rashes in the skin etc
and this is transmitted by a specific
tick
so i hope this particular video was
informative and you get an overview that
how
spirochetes are involved in human
diseases so if you like this video give
it a quick thumbs up you can also get
all the notes in my facebook channel
link is provided in the description
as usual don't forget to like share and
subscribe you can support my channel on
patreon you can also support me via beam
upi app
now my courses are present in unacademy
which is india's biggest learning
platform by using my code ap 10 you can
get a 10 discount see you in the next
video thank you